All right.
Welcome back to Computer Vision.
Today, we're going to start heading
up the Computer Vision food chain.
We started with basic
images as functions.
We did some image processing,
edge detection, manipulation.
Then we did some low-level computation
of vision and things like motion,
stereo.
We considered some geometry,
such as things like essential and
fundamental matrices that related how
cameras were viewing a scene, panoramas,
sift features, et cetera.
Even the tracking of objects.
But all of that stuff is
really semantic-free.
And what I mean by semantic-free is
there was no notion of what the object
was, what you and I would refer to it.
So when I look at the table, I see a,
a cup of coffee that I paid way too much
money for
at some really expensive coffee shop,
because that's what we all do
in academia in these days.
But the idea is that I know that,
that thing is a cup of coffee.
So for this section and a little bit
of the discussions going forward,
we're going to be talking
about recognition.
Recognition being
the labeling of the object.
In particular,
we typically think of it as
labeling objects with labels
that humans would understand.
The other thing I want to say before
we get in is we're only going to do
a little bit of this.
And that's because object re,
recognition has become hugely
driven by machine learning.
Machine learning is a general field
where you have lots of data that
some of which is, is often labeled or
supervised, described what's there.
And you have training data and
you use that to be able to do label or
categorize or
describe some new novel input.
We're going to talk a little bit about
that, but only a little little, because
machine learning is such a big field
that if you want to understand more of
the details, you, you almost have to
take an entire machine learning course.
So we'll be touching on the underlying
machine learning methods,
especially a couple lessons from now.
But mostly, we'll try to talk a bit
about how its been applied to
a Computer Vision scenario.